one of the fastest ways to grow your
business is to sell more to current
customers it's way easier to get
customers who you're already working
with to buy more from you than to go out
and try to find new customers and if
you're trying to figure out what new
things you can sell to your current
customers talk to them ask them let them
know what else can I do to help you
understand their problems their pains
and offer solutions for them hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and today I
mention a question from one of my
readers Michael who wrote insane I offer
door-to-door delivery services the
people from groceries the dry cleaning
office lunch pizza many other things I
would like to know what I can improve on
other things I can have like selling
water to my lunch love your customers or
any other ideas that you have in mind in
this kind of service business you're
selling the people who value their time
more than you value their money they're
hiring you because you're going to save
them time I like that you're thinking
bigger I like that you're thinking that
pizza in lunch and dry cleaning is not
enough you want to grow this bigger the
best way to do it is go talk to your
customers every time you go and you
deliver them something you want to ask
them what else you could do for them
thank you so much for this order if
there's anything else that I can do to
deliver for you please let me know some
of my other customers are horror me 4 X
4 y + 4 z I'd be happy to do that for
you or if there's anything else that you
have in mind I'd love to try to take it
on just let me know and that way you're
building around customers who are paying
you money it's the best way to do it I
made a mistake early on in my career a
pretty big mistake that auto sunk my
company we were in software and we built
this feature that took us months to
develop that we thought was really
helpful and when we finally launched it
it turns out our customer
didn't care about it almost at all and
we were heartbroken that we spent so
much time and dollars and effort on this
feature that if we had invested that
time doing something else the software
could be much better and luckily we
still had enough enough great features
in it that we were able to get customers
and sell the software but from then on
all of our new features everything new
we added to the business came directly
from our customers it came from them
telling us what they wanted and also us
understanding their pain in their
problems customers may not always tell
you exactly what you need to do because
maybe they don't know but they will tell
you their problems they'll tell you
what's causing a frustration for them
and maybe you could think of a way that
helped solve it for them so if you want
to grow your business start talking to
your customers more understand what
their pains are and think of solutions
and you can offer to help them grow to
help them save more time that's what
you're there for that's why they're
hiring you and if they like you for your
delivery service at your offer now
chances are they give you a good shot at
doing other services as well because
they know you like you trust you and
it's easy to say yes to you good luck
I'm excited let me know how it goes for
those of you watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it always makes you want to do more
videos for you and I'd love to hear we
have to think about this video or if you
have a question for your own business
please leave it in the comments below I
always read those I love seeing them and
reading them they always make my day so
thank you and I'll see you on the next
episode
you
you
you